Bonjour répondeur, mon vieil ami.
(Rires)
J'apelle encore le support technique.
J'ai ignoré le conseil de mon chef. J'ai appelé un lundi matin.
C'est maintenant le soir, et mon diner commença par être froid - puis moisi
Je suis toujours en attente. J'écoute le son du silence.
Je ne pense pas que vous comprenez. Je pense que vos lignes ne sont pas assez couvertes.
J'ai appuyé sur tous les boutons qu'on m'a dit.
mais je reste toujours 18 heures en attente.
Comme si c'était pas suffisant votre programme a fait planter mon Mac et
il plante et replante constamment -- il a effacé mes ROMS! Maintenant le Mac
fait le son du silence.
Dans mes rêves je fantasme
d'abattre ma vengeance sur vous les gars.
Disons que vous avez un accident de moto
du sang jailli de vos entrailles. Avec vos dernières forces,
vous appelez le 9-1-1 et vous priez pour un médecin experimenté. Mais vous m'avez moi
(Rires)
et vous écoutez le son du silence.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Bonsoir et bienvenue au
"Trouvez le présentateur TED qui était avant un accompagnateur sur Broadway"
(Rires)
OK. Quand on m'a proposé d'écrire pour le Times il y a 6 ans,
l'arrangement était le suivant: on m'enverrait les gadgets, les plus cool, les plus demandés, et les plus tendance.
Chaque semaine ils arriveraient chez moi.
Pour que je les essaie, joue avec, et que je les évalue
jusqu'à ce que la nouveauté s'estompe, avant de les renvoyer.
Et je serais payé pour ça. Je pouvais y réfléchir, si je voulais.
Bon j'ai toujours été un fou de technologie, et j'adore toujours autant ça.
À part que le boulot est venu avec un petit désagrément. Et c'était que,
ils avaient l'intention de publier mon adresse email a la fin de chaque article.
Et ce que j'ai remarqué c'est -- d'abord, vous recevez un nombre incroyable d'emails.
Si jamais vous vous sentez seul,
écrivez pour le New York Times, parce que vous aller recevoir des centaines et
des centaines et des centaines d'emails. Et l'email que je reçois le plus
ces jours traite de frustration.
Les gens ont le sentiment que les choses -- OK,
juste un message d'alarme sur mon écran. Heureusement vous ne le voyez pas.
Les gens ont le sentiment d'être dépassés. Que c'est trop de technologie, trop vite.
C'est peut-être de la bonne technologie,
mais j'ai l'impression qu'il n'y a pas assez de structure de support.
Il n'y a pas assez d'aide. Il n'y a pas assez de recherche
mise dans le design pour le rendre facile et agréable à utiliser.
Une fois j'ai écrit un article sur mes efforts pour joindre
l’assistance technique de Dell. Et en 12 heures,
il y a eu plus de 700 messages de lecteurs sur le forum
sur le site web du Times, d'utilisateurs disant, "Moi aussi!" et,
"Voici mon expérience malheureuse." J'appelle ça la rage du logiciel.
Et laissez moi vous dire, celui qui arrivera à transformer en argent
cette frustration va --
oh, d'où ça sort? Je plaisante.
(Rires)
Ok, bon pourquoi est-ce que le problème s'accélère ? Et une partie du problème est,
ironiquement, parce que l'industrie a fait tellement de recherche
pour rendre les choses plus simples à utiliser.
Je vais vous montrer ce que je veux dire.
Voici à quoi ressemblait l'interface d'un ordinateur, DOS.
Au fil du temps c'est devenu plus simple à utiliser.
Voici le système d'exploitation Mac d'origine.
Reagan était président. Madonna était encore brune.
Et tout le système d'exploitation --
attention -- tout le système d'exploitation tenait dans 211k.
Le logo de Mac OS 10 ne tiendrait pas dans 211k!
(Rires)
Et l'ironie c'est que comme ces choses devenaient plus faciles à utiliser
un public moins technique et plus large entrait en contact
avec cet équipement pour la première fois.
J'ai eu une fois le privilège de rester au centre d'appel d'Apple toute une journée.
Le gars avait un deuxième casque pour que je puisse entendre.
Les appels qui -- vous savez ce qu'ils disent,
"Votre appel peut être enregistré pour les besoins de la formation?"
Mm-Mmm. Votre appel peut être enregistré
pour qu'ils puissent avoir les histoires les plus drôles d'utilisateurs stupides
et se les passer sur CD.
(Rires)
Ce qu'ils font.
Et j'ai une copie.
(Rires)
C'est dans votre sac-cadeau. Non, non.
Votre voix est dessus.
Certaines histoires sont tellement classiques, et pourtant si compréhensibles.
Une dame a appelé Apple pour se plaindre
que sa souris grinçait -- qu'elle émettait un son grinçant.
Et le technicien a dit, "Bon, madame, qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par votre souris grince?"
Elle a dit, "Tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
plus vite je la bouge sur l'écran plus elle grince fort
(Rires)
Et le technicien étonné, "Madame, vous avez la souris contre l'écran?"
Elle répond, "Bon, le message disait, 'cliquer ici pour continuer.'"
(Rires)
Bon si vous aimez celle-là, combien de temps avons-nous ?
Une autre, un gars a appelé. Ceci est véridique!
Son ordinateur avait planté, et il a dit au technicien
qu'il ne pouvait pas redémarrer peut importe combien de fois il tapait 11.
Et le technicien a dit, "Quoi? Pourquoi êtes vous en train de taper 11?" Et il a dit,
"Le message dit, 'Erreur Type (taper) 11.'"
(Rires)
Bon on doit admettre qu'une partie de la faute est dûe à l'utilisateur.
Mais pourquoi est-ce que la crise technique,
la crise de complexité, s'accélère maintenant? Dans le monde du matériel,
c'est parce que nous consommateurs voulons que tout soit toujours plus petit.
Donc les gadgets deviennent minuscules
mais nos doigts restent toujours de la même taille.
C'est donc toujours plus difficile.
Le logiciel est sujet à une autre force primaire:
Le mandat de publier toujours plus de versions.
Quand on achète un logiciel, ce n'est pas comme acheter un vase
ou un bonbon, que l'on possède.
C'est plus comme adhérer à un club où l'on paie la cotisation chaque année.
Et chaque année, ils disent,
"Nous avons ajouté plus de fonctions et nous allons vous les vendre pour 99 dollars"
Je connais un gars qui a dépensé 4000 dollars rien que sur Photoshop au fil des ans.
Et les éditeurs de logiciels tirent 35 pour cent de leurs revenus
rien que de ces mises à jour.
J'appelle ça le Paradoxe de la Mise à Jour --
qui est que si on améliore un logiciel suffisamment de fois,
au final on le ruine.
Je veux dire, Microsoft Word était juste un traitement de texte, vous savez,
pendant l'administration Eisenhower.
(Rires)
Mais quelle est l'alternative? Microsoft a fait l'essai. Ils ont dit,
"Bon, attendez une minute. Tout le monde se plaint que nous ajoutons trop de fonctions.
Créons un traitement de texte qui est seulement un traitement de texte.
Simple, pur, il ne fait pas de pages web, ce n'est pas une base de données."
Et c'est sorti. Cela s'appelait Microsoft Write.
Et personne de vous n'approuve de la tête, parce que c'est mort.
Ce fut un flop. Personne ne l'a jamais acheté.
J'appelle ça le Principe de l'Utilitaire Sportif. Les gens aiment s'entourer
de puissance inutile, pas vrai?
Ils n'ont pas besoin de la base de données et du site web, mais ils se disent,
"Bon, je vais mettre à jour, car, je pourrais, vous savez. Je pourrais en avoir besoin un jour!"
Donc, le problème est, quand vous ajoutez des fonctions, où est-ce qu'elles vont aller?
Où est-ce que vous allez les mettre? Vous avez un nombre limité d'options.
Boutons, glissières, menus déroulants, sous-menus.
Mais si vous ne faites pas attention, vous vous retrouvez avec ça.
(Rires)
Ceci n'a pas été retouché -- ce n'est une blague -- photo non retouchée de Microsoft Word,
la copie que vous avez, avec toutes les barres de fonctions ouvertes.
Vous ne les avez apparemment jamais toutes ouvertes
et tout ce qui vont reste pour taper c'est cette petite, minuscule fenêtre ici en bas.
(Rires)
Et nous sommes arrivé a l'ère des interfaces matricielles, où il y a
tellement de fonctions et d'options, que vous avez besoin de deux dimensions, vous savez.
Une verticale et une horizontale. Vous les gars vous vous êtes tous plaints
de Microsoft Word qui numérote vos liste et souligne vos liens automatiquement.
Le bouton d'arrêt est quelque part par là.
Je vous dis, il est là!
Une partie de l'art de concevoir une bonne, et simple interface,
c'est de savoir quand utiliser chacune de ces fonctions.
Donc voici la fenêtre d'arrêt de Windows 2000.
Il y a seulement quatre choix.
alors pourquoi sont-ils dans un menu déroulant?
Ce n'est pas comme si le reste de l'écran était tellement plein d'autres composants
que vous avez besoin de fusionner les choix
Ils auraient pu tous les rendre visibles.
Voici la vision d'Apple sur la même fenêtre.
(Applaudissements)
Merci -- oui, j'ai conçu la fenêtre de dialogue. Non, non, non.
Déjà, nous pouvons voir qu'Apple et Microsoft
ont une approche sévèrement divergente du design de logiciels.
La simplicité selon Microsoft ressemble plutôt à:
on va le fractionner, on va inclure plus d'étapes
Et il y a ces assistants partout.
Et vous savez, une nouvelle version de Windows sort cet automne.
S’ils continuent à ce rythme, personne ne peut dire
où ils vont finir.
(Applaudissements)
Bienvenue à l'assistant Taper-Un-Mot. OK, J'accroche. Cliquons sur suivant pour continuer.
À partir du menu déroulant choisissez la première lettre à taper. OK.
(Rires)
Il y a donc une limite qu'il ne faut pas franchir. Alors quelle est la solution?
Comment intégrer toutes ces fonctions d'une manière intelligente et simple?
Je crois dans la cohérence quand c'est possible,
équivalents réels, dossiers poubelle quand c'est possible, surtout étiqueter les choses
Mais je supplie ici les développeurs d'enfreindre
toutes ces règles si elles violent la plus grande règle de toutes,
qui est l'intelligence. Maintenant qu'est ce que je veux dire par là?
Je vais donner un exemple où l'intelligence fait que quelque chose
n'est pas cohérent, mais mieux.
Si vous achetez quelque chose sur le web, vous êtes censé mettre votre adresse et
vous êtes supposé choisir de quel pays vous êtes, ok?
Il y a 200 pays dans le monde. On aime à penser de l'Internet que c'est un village global
Je suis désolé, ça ne l'est pas encore.
C'est principalement, les États-Unis, l'Europe et le Japon.
Donc pourquoi les États-Unis sont-ils dans les "U"?
(Rires)
Vous devez faire défiler, comme sept écrans complets pour y arriver.
Maintenant ce ne serait pas cohérent de mettre les États-Unis en premier,
mais ça serait intelligent. Celui-là a été abordé avant,
mais pourquoi est-ce que vous éteignez un PC Windows en cliquant
sur un bouton appelé "Démarrer?"
(Rires)
Voici un autre de mes favoris: vous avez une imprimante.
La plupart du temps, vous voulez imprimer seulement une copie de votre document,
dans l'ordre, sur cette imprimante.
Alors pourquoi est-ce que vous voyez chaque fois ça?
C'est comme un cockpit de 747.
(Rires)
Et un des boutons en bas, vous le remarquerez, n'est pas "Imprimer."
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, je ne dis pas qu'Apple est la seule compagnie qui a adopté
le culte de la simplicité.
Palm aussi, spécialement dans l'ancien temps, ils étaient formidable pour ça.
Je suis allé parler chez Palm quand ils étaient populaires dans les années 90,
et après la présentation, j'ai rencontré un des employés.
Il a dit, "jolie présentation." Et j'ai dit, "Merci, quel est votre rôle ici?"
Il a dit, "Je suis un compteur de taps."
Étonné, "Vous êtes quoi?" Il continue, "En fait, Jeff Hawkins, le président, dit,
'Si n'importe quelle tâche sur le Palm Pilot prend plus de trois taps du stylet,
c'est trop long, et doit être repensé.' Donc je suis le compteur de taps."
Je vais donc vous montrer un exemple d'une compagnie qui n'a pas
de compteur de taps.
Ceci est Microsoft Word, OK. Pour créer un nouveau document vierge dans Word
-- ça peut arriver!
(Rires)
Vous allez dans le menu Fichier et vous choisissez "Nouveau." Maintenant,
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vous choisissez "nouveau?" Est-ce que vous créez un nouveau document vierge?
Non pas du tout.
À l'opposé de l'écran, une fenêtre apparait, et quelque part
dans ces liens -- et bien sûr pas tout en haut -- quelque part dans ces liens
il y a un bouton qui vous crée un nouveau document.
Ok, ceci est donc une compagnie qui ne compte pas les taps.
Vous savez, je ne veux pas seulement être là pour plaisanter sur Microsoft.
Public: Allez-y.
David Pogue: Oui je le veux.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
La chanson de Bill Gates!
J'ai depuis toujours été un fou d'informatique et j'ai écrit le tout premier DOS.
J'ai mis mon logiciel et IBM ensemble;
J'ai eu les profits et ils ont eu les pertes.
(Rires)
J'écris le code qui fait tourner le monde entier.
Je reçois des droits d’auteurs de tout le monde.
Des fois, c'est pourri mais la presse est impressionnée.
Vous achetez la boite, je vends le code.
Toutes les compagnies font de la recherche pour Microsoft.
Vous ne pouvez plus garder une bonne idée secrète de nos jours.
Même Windows est une copie. On est vaguement basés sur le Mac.
C'est si gros, c'est si lent. Vous n'avez nulle part où aller. Je ne le fais pas pour la reconnaissance;
J'écris le code qui plaît au monde aujourd'hui.
D'une médiocrité absolue,
Nous sommes entrés dans un mode de domination de la planète
Vous n'aurez pas le choix, vous achèterez mon code.
Je suis Bill Gates et j'écris le code.
(Applaudissements)
Mais en fait, je pense qu'il y a vraiment deux Microsofts.
Il y a l'ancien, responsable de Windows et Office.
Ils meurent d'envie de tout balancer et recommencer à zéro
mais ils ne peuvent pas. Ils sont coincés, car il y a tellement d'ajouts
et de choses maison qui les condamnent à rester sur le vieux châssis de 1982.
Mais il y a aussi un nouveau Microsoft qui est vraiment en train de faire
des design d'interfaces bons et simples.
J'aime le PC Media Center. J'ai aimé la montre Microsoft SPOT.
La montre sans fil a été un terrible échec dans le marché,
mais ce n'était pas qu'elle n'était pas simplement et élégamment faite.
Mettons les choses en perspective: payeriez-vous
10 dollars par mois pour avoir une montre qui doit être rechargée chaque nuit,
comme votre mobile, et qui s'arrête de fonctionner quand vous quittez votre code postal?
(Rires)
Les signes peuvent indiquer que la période de complexité va seulement empirer.
Reste-t-il encore un espoir? Les écrans deviennent plus petits.
Les gens sont en train d'éliminer les manuels dans les boites.
Les choses sortent à une cadence plus rapide.
C'est marrant -- quand Steve Jobs est revenu à Apple en 1997,
après être parti pendant 12 ans, c'était l'exposition Macworld.
Il arriva sur la scène dans son col roulé noir et ses jeans, et
il a fait quelque chose comme ça. La foule était en délire, mais
Je me dis, où est ce que j'ai vu ça avant? Je venais de voir le film "Evita" --
(Rires)
-- avec Madonna, et je me suis dit, vous savez quoi, je dois en faire une sur Steve Jobs.
Ce ne sera pas facile. Vous pensez que je suis bizarre.
Quand j'essaie d'expliquer pourquoi je suis revenu
après avoir dit à la presse que le futur d'Apple est noir.
Vous ne me croirez pas.
Tout ce que vous voyez c'est un ado qui a démarré dans un garage
avec rien qu'un pote nommé Woz.
(Rires)
Essayez de rimer avec garage!
Ne pleure pas pour moi, Cupertino.
(Rires)
La vérité c'est, que je ne t'ai jamais laissé.
Je connais les ficelles maintenant, je sais quels sont les trucs.
J'ai fait fortune grâce à Pixar.
(Rires)
Ne pleure pas pour moi, Cupertino. J'ai toujours une vision très claire
Je porte toujours des sandales pendant n'importe quel temps. C'est juste que ces jours,
c'est du cuir Gucci.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Donc Steve Jobs a toujours cru dans la simplicité
l'élégance et la beauté. Et à dire vrai
pendant des années j'étais un peu déprimé. C'était évident que les Américains n'y accordaient aucun prix,
parce que le Mac avait trois pour cent de part de marché,
Windows avait 95 pour cent de part de marché.
Les gens ne pensaient pas que ça valait la peine de payer pour ça..
Donc j'étais un peu déprimé, et puis j'ai entendu la présentation d’Al Gore, et j'ai réalisé
que je ne savais pas ce que déprimé veut dire.
(Rires)
Mais en fait il s’est avéré que j'avais tort, d'accord ? Car l'iPod est arrivé,
Et il a violé toutes les règles du bon sens.
D'autres produits coûtaient moins. D'autres produits avaient plus d'options.
Ils avaient des enregistreurs de voix, et des récepteurs FM.
Les autres produits étaient supportés par Microsoft avec un standard ouvert,
pas le standard fermé d'Apple.
Mais l'iPod gagna! C'est celui qu'ils voulaient.
La leçon était: la simplicité vend.
Et il y a des signes qui indiquent que l'industrie est en train de recevoir le message.
Voici une petite compagnie qui a très bien réussi tout en simplicité et en élégance.
Le Sonos -- c'est en train de prendre..
J'ai juste deux exemples. Physiquement, une pensée vraiment sympa,
et élégante qui est arrivé récemment.
Quand vous avez un appareil numérique, comment transférez-vous les photos à votre ordinateur?
Bon, soit vous trimbalez partout un câble USB, soit vous achetez un lecteur de cartes et le trimbalez partout.
L'un ou l'autre, vous allez le perdre. Ce que je fais, c'est que je sors
la carte mémoire, et je la plie en deux, révélant ainsi un port USB.
Je le branche dans l'ordinateur, transfère les photos, et le remets en place
dans l'appareil. Comme ça je n'ai rien à perdre.
Voici un autre exemple. Chris, tu es la source de toute la puissance.
Voudrais-tu être ma prise électrique?
Chris Anderson: Oui bien sûr.
DP: Tiens ça et ne le lâche pas. Vous avez peut-être vu ceci:
c'est le nouveau portable Apple. Voici le cordon d'alimentation. On le branche comme ça.
Et je suis sûr que vous avez tous déjà fait ça à un moment ou un autre,
ou un de vos enfants. Vous marchez, et
Je m'apprête à le balancer par terre. Je n'en ai rien à faire. C'est un prêt.
On y va. Whoa! C'est magnétique. Ça ne fait pas tomber l'ordinateur par terre.
(Applaudissements)
Dans mon tout dernier exemple -- Je fais une grande partie de mon travail
en utilisant un programme de reconnaissance vocale, et vous devez rester tranquille
parce que le programme est nerveux. Ok.
La reconnaissance vocale est super pour écrire des emails très rapidement. Point.
Comme, j'en reçois des centaines par jour. Point.
Il n'écrit pas seulement ce que je dicte. Point.
J'utilise aussi une des fonctions appelée macros. Point.
Corriger "dissuadé ". Pas seulement.
Ok, ce n'est pas une situation idéale,
car il reçoit de l'écho de la salle,et ce genre de truc.
Mais l'important c'est que je peux répondre aux gens
très rapidement en disant un mot court qu'il développe
en quelque chose de beaucoup plus long. Si quelqu'un m'écrit un mail de fan, je dirai
"Merci pour ça."
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Au contraire, si quelqu'un m'écrit un mail méchant -- ce qui arrive tous les jours --
Je dis, "Va chier."
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Donc ceci est mon petit secret personnel. Ne le dites à personne.
(Rires)
Donc le principal est que c'est une histoire très intéressante.
Ceci est la 8e version du logiciel, et vous savez ce qu'ils ont mis dans cette 8e version?
Pas de nouvelles fonctions. Ce n'est jamais encore arrivé dans le monde du logiciel!
La compagnie n'a pas mis de nouvelles fonctions. Ils ont juste dit,
"Nous allons faire fonctionner le programme correctement." Bien.
Parce que pendant des années les personnes ont acheté ce logiciel, l'ont essayé --
95 pour cent de précision était tout ce qu'ils recevaient, ce qui veut dire qu'un mot sur 20 est faux --
et il le rangeait dans leurs tiroirs. Et la compagnie était fatiguée de ça,
donc ils ont dit, "Dans cette version, vous n'allons rien faire d'autre que
nous assurer qu'elle est sacrément précise."
Et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait. Cette façon de bien faire les choses est en train de s'étendre.
Donc mon dernier conseil pour ceux qui sont des consommateurs de cette technologie:
Souvenez-vous, si ça ne fonctionne pas ce n'est pas forcément de votre faute, OK?
ça peut être le design de la chose que vous utilisez.
Soyez sensibles dans la vie au bon et au mauvais design.
Et si vous faites partie des gens qui créent ces choses, facile est dur.
Souffrez par avance pour votre public. Comptez les taps.
Et souvenez-vous, la chose la plus dure n'est pas de savoir quelle fonction inclure --
c'est de décider ce qu'il faut laisser de côté.
Et le plus important de tout, votre motivation est: la simplicité vend.
CA: Bravo
DP: Merci beaucoup.
CA: Encore bravo!
(Applaudissements)